all right so again you had drill one
that's a Stillness solo Stillness
drill okay and then um and you got to
you got to spend time doing that okay
like your whole day you got to be doing
that and then we had our partner drill
so I'm doing my solo drill I still do my
solo drill here so he's pushing okay and
uh I nothing should change when I can
get this to feel just like I'm by
myself
I'm good to go drill
three I don't I don't have a front foot
so I catch with my qua I catch with my
qua now one of the whole points of doing
the seated C you drill set
is the act is to bring the qua into it
okay uh and of course you're taking away
your bracing angles you should use your
claw when you're standing but you're a
beginner so you don't know okay so we
taken away the bracing angle and we're
more geared towards letting the clad
drop and uh become part of our engine
okay so on drill three he's going to
come in okay and when I catch this I
catch this in my
quad and then I come forward so catching
the claw when I catch in the claw I
don't break
everything okay catching the
quaw there's a timing to catch it is a
timing if I'm here and then I can I can
catch that but you're going to get a
little less reaction as opposed to his
initial
reaction and to move forward this is
more important
so I'm moving forward I catching the
quaw and my chest moves forward
okay my arms don't go my arms aren't
doing anything
qua through walk
in there's no it's not that I'm trying
to make him go he's doing a a a back
breake ball and I kind of just follow
him wherever the energy
is make him go it doesn't matter I'm not
trying to make him fall I'm just doing
the mechanics catch
[Music]
ground okay let's
try all right
uh don't don't come up in his shoulders
so don't don't lock him don't lock him
in and that's what you I don't I don't
really care what what's happening okay
uh so you can see his arms are bent I
still have his Center I still have his s
okay so I'm not and so I don't I don't
try to get a skeletal alignment in him
and then push of course that's something
you can do okay but it's not what we're
after uh and then also watch that as now
you're task with not just staying still
but to move him that's where people get
tense they start doing like that oh just
as I was by myself and I feel all that
tension free the same thing is here as I
move okay I shouldn't I shouldn't
be all this kind of stuff it's very
tension free and I'm moving
catch so in the same way that if he was
here and he was pushing and you feel
some tension I want you to release the
tension okay I want you to release the
tension same thing as you go to now
displace him you're going to feel the
tension I want you to release the
tension catch
[Music]
full
okay try it again so on the next drill I
I everything that I was just trying to
do I'm going to make as small as
possible okay that that's what I'm
trying to do and
uh as immediate as
[Music]
possible
okay let's try so on this on this one
it's very tempting to see you touched me
you touch me and I go back and then in
some way I go I adapt and then go in you
see or my pelvis moves this one is in
place like right at contact
boom so that that catch happens pre
contact right when you touch
[Music]
me but it's not
this okay it's a little C it's like
right as soon as as right as soon as you
touch I've caught it and by the time the
rest of the grip came on Boom it was
ready to project okay so
catching
different you see but also
different Okay
[Music]
so
okay